do you think Alohomora would work for
opening people's minds so as we draw
ever closer to the release of new Harry
Potter material ie the next fantastic
beast film I've kind of got Harry Potter
on the brain a bit so I want to talk
about my house Slytherin I've mentioned
it before and I kind of want to talk
about just in general my coming to to
terms with being Slytherin because it
was something I kind of resisted for a
bit for a number of reasons but let's go
back I I don't know when I started I
know I was reading the books before the
first movie came out but them I knew the
movies were being made so that I think
there might have been a link there like
I knew they were gonna be movies
eventually anyway let me read the books
which actually is the opposite of how I
tend to think about the best way to do
it now but maybe I'll save that for
another video sometime so I had you know
read these and I was I was pretty much
at my most into them in college in the
years following which was you know when
they were still being released by the
time I got into the series the first
four books had come out I was yeah I was
actually working at a bookstore when
when order of the Phoenix came out that
was not fun
that was insane and so you know I I was
through it with all of that and then
followed it so still in the middle of
all this I long before Pottermore was a
thing for you to get sort of sorted
officially you know I used to take the
boy this is gonna date myself the sort
of quizzes you would see on things like
LiveJournal that people would always
link to for you know their results and I
take those kinds of
you know to find out my house or my
Patronus or things like that and I was
rarely happy with the results now that's
not to say that I was always getting
sorted into Slytherin but in my head
especially at that point I really
thought I was a ravenclaw guy I kept
trying to force that result
uh-hum out of whatever quiz I was taking
and sometimes I would succeed and if I
didn't I would just think well there's a
badly done quiz you know like you do
when you're you know young and think
that you get to dictate to the world how
things are instead of the world kind of
tells you so I you know I think part of
the reason like I knew I knew I was
never ignored that was never even an
option for me and I knew it wasn't
that's just not like fundamentally
that's not who I am I'm not that
headstrong I'm not that honestly I'm not
that sure myself I mean you know you
even want to talk about stuff you know I
have my opinions and I have my feelings
but I qualify the heck out of almost
everything I say I don't deal in
absolutes you know I don't deal in that
level of certainty very often and that
and that kind of is the you know the
Gryffindor stock-in-trade the reason
they're as brave and as bold as there is
because there's that certain of
themselves I'm not so I always knew I
was not a Gryffindor like that's the
that's the thing that I am the least of
anything and you know hufflepuff I don't
think I ever had a problem with
Hufflepuff but especially as the books
were coming out I felt like I didn't
really know who they were so like I
didn't have feelings about that so like
if I would take a quiz and get sorry at
the Hufflepuff I just I honestly didn't
know what to make of Adam like I don't
know what to do with that information
and sort of the prejudice against
Slytherin came largely from the way that
they are primarily depicted in the books
and the movies and I will get to that so
you know there was sort of in the back
of my head I thought for a very long
time like I think I'm a Ravenclaw like I
can be a bit analytical you know I can
you know I like to pick up things a
little bit but in there
felt that strongly cuz you know I'm not
I'm a little analytical but I'm not
deeply analytical I like to sort of pick
stuff enough that I know okay I
basically get it from here like I don't
like to deep analyze stuff that's not
where my head goes you know that's sort
of real break let's break it down to
those component parts understand
everything that's not me either
and you know that's also not how my how
my head works so eventually when
Pottermore was up
I initially I ignored it I ignored it
for years I don't think I officially
sorted myself until I wasn't all that
long ago but the thing was I had sort of
felt myself even before taking the the
current test as it exists on Pottermore
and getting sorted into Slytherin I had
found myself thinking prior to that boy
you know Slytherin as a group really is
the short shrift in this narrative and I
so I in the intervening years I had
softened up on the ideas of Slytherin
not just thinking of them as love bad
guys so by the time I got properly
sorted I was at a place myself and with
enough self understanding and self
acceptance that I was able to look at
that result and go yeah yeah yeah so
what does it mean to be a Slytherin well
slytherins are many things and like
honestly anything they are many things
that can be twisted in a bad way but
let's just talk raw qualities we are
coming we are pragmatic we are end
results focused we don't act like that
we have a tendency to really carefully
think about what are the outcomes of the
different possible ways of handling this
and what one is the best one and then
sort of where that and we have the
potential it's not a given but we have
potential to be very self-centered in
that because approaching things from
that mindset lends itself to thinking
what's the best outcome of all these
options for me so you kind of have to
have it in your head and thinking you
you you have to consciously if it's not
in your nature think okay what's the
best outcome for those involved and
we're more than capable of expanding
that thought out but you know that is
kind of a trap for Slytherin sometimes
and it's one that I I used to fall into
it I was kind of in denial about that
for a while which I get again is one of
the reasons I think I resisted the
notion of being Slytherin which was that
I I knew that you know five ten years
ago it was my worst tendencies that
tended to play into the the Slytherin
elements or at least the way those
elements were part of me they were
leaning towards the way it goes bad with
Slytherin but Southerners are also you
know they're not quick to make friends
but they are fiercely loyal were the
people who they choose to make their
friends and I do not have a particularly
long list of close friends it's I mean
I've got a fair number of friends I've
got a large number of acquaintances
pretty good number of friends close
friends like I'm this is somebody I call
when if everything falls apart
these are people I can I can reach out
to and call three and but you know those
people mean the world to me
and you know that I think that's another
sort of typical southern trait and I and
you know the the books were always gonna
be a bit biased against Slytherin
because they're from the perspective of
a Gryffindor and because Gryffindor's
are very much about certainty the moral
certainty of their own standing they
have a tendency and in kind of an
inherent distrust of people who aren't
just so sure of themselves what do you
mean you have to stop and think about it
what is there
it's obviously this and you know that
there's there's a reason that there's an
inherent distrust on both sides slow
learners by their nature accounting
Ghana distrust somebody who is that
friggin sure of themselves without
putting a ton of thought into it and
Gryffindor's are gonna be cautious
around anyone who seems that wofully
like doesn't have firm pillars and
certainties in their life so you know
get talking about what's like to sort of
cope with being a slow the big thing
that you have to deal with if you're a
Slytherin is pointing out and I do in my
own comments whenever this comes up I
well you know the Death Eaters because
yes most of the Death Eaters that we
where we know who they were or
slytherins and most of the students at
Hogwarts who had who maybe weren't Death
Eaters directly but had an affiliation
or a desire to appeal to them were
slytherins
so yeah I mean that is the thing you
have to deal with and I'm very quick in
my own comment section if that gets
brought up too hashtag not all
slytherins but at the same time that's a
little bit dismissive you have to deal
with your own potential worst elements
and like the the way I it if you are to
make Voldemort's desire for purity
basically racial purity pure blood if
you were to make that analogous to Nazis
then Slytherin as a house is Germany the
vast majority of Nazis were German not
all Germans were Nazis but at the same
time yeah hat you can't just go well
that's not us and then not deal with it
you you have to and that's kind of why I
mentioned at the front end talking about
how I had to kind of come to a better
understanding of myself and my own
failings and potential pitfalls and bad
habits that and understand how yeah that
could feed into the bad end of this
spectrum but yeah
so don't have to be that and it's one of
the things that I really wish JK rowling
had given a little bit more acknowledge
of us it like in the in the final book
especially it like I don't mind it so
much how black and white it is like
slytherins bad early on because the you
know the books are from Harry's
perspective he's 11 on the things
started he's got to see the world in
pretty black-and-white terms it it's a
little bit frustrating for me that as it
goes along as it gets to the tail end
and the chips you really get laid down
that it's still being dealt with in
those terms and when the Battle of
Hogwarts begins this the solution is
we're gonna put everyone who's in
Slytherin house and lock them up we're
not even gonna risk it and again I I get
it and I'm not saying that that wasn't a
viable option but like somebody saying
you know they're not all bad and we
could use the help and you know somebody
going book we cannot risk it right now
we'll figure this out late you know just
something this is some back and forth
cuz because otherwise it feels like it
validates the whole notion of all
slytherins are bad and you know that's a
little unfortunate for the last book
seeing that she was writing the
characters and the work as a whole was
aging with its audience it was getting
more adult it was getting more mature it
was getting darker was getting more
nuanced but it was still dealing with
slytherins and very black-and-white
terms which was annoying and also now
I'd add at this point going back seeing
especially the first up it's become a
joke among Potterheads Dumbledore's
tendency to go nicely done Slytherin
winning the house Cup too bad I'm giving
it to Gryffindor like that's a joke at
this point but it's like yep like lots
of people have lots of different issues
with Dumbledore for various reasons but
slytherins tend to have that one you
self-serving bastard so you know what
does it mean to come to terms with your
own house I think if you're not a
Gryffindor and you know you're not a
Gryffindor that is something that you
tend to have to
because Gryffindor's who we see the most
of in the books in the movies and it is
nice that we are now getting say a
really good Hufflepuff representative in
the form of newt scamander in the
fantastic beast films and as far as
Raven claw goes we do have Luna who I
mean loon is weird enough that I feel
like maybe there should be a slightly
less crazy representative for Raven
cause as well but you know I think she
also kind of gives you the ballpark you
know that that sort of way of looking at
things
but with Slytherin like the best we've
had as an attempt as a curative to try
and fix Slytherin image is the cursed
child and the cursed child oh I gotta
talk about that at some point but that
that that would be a whole other video
it's yeah I'm not gonna talk about that
thank you it's it's a divisive piece of
work and a lot of fans just basically
ignore it so to have that kind of be the
major sea slytherins aren't all that bad
piece of work and nobody likes it not
because of that but because of other
stuff that doesn't help but you know I I
take pride in my house I take pride in
the qualities that I have because I yeah
I have these qualities I I will look at
outcomes more than I will look at what's
the principled best thing and that's not
and that's not say I don't have
principles but I can't stop my brain
from going what's the forget what's the
quote unquote proper thing to do what's
the real-world consequence of XYZ and
whether or not I choose to override that
and go on a principled stance or not I
can't stop my brain from at the very
least running that calculation and
that's a pretty dang Slytherin thing to
do
and I I have really come I mean yeah
come to embrace that mean look at this
I've got the tie I've got this yeah yeah
there we go I've got a pin I've got a
winter hat haven't got a scarf yet I got
to get one can see that this is what I'm
talking about and as long as you know I
have to remember not to get too overly
snippy with people when they like
weights you support Voldemort no no
attempt because that is the bat that is
the worst end that is the worst of what
we are capable of and I think that you
could very easily in future works
related to Harry Potter if it was chosen
to do so you could very easily have the
worst possible version of any of the
houses be a villain I think you could
have a worse possible version of a
Gryffindor well I mean arguably would
kind maybe we saw that with Wormtail but
I don't know his qualities don't really
line up all that well but I mean like
somebody who is so absolutely sure of
themselves that they are in the right
and don't stop and question that that
works as long as they are in fact on the
right side of things if they're not
that's scary
with ravenclaw the worst possible
version is someone who's just interested
in the data in the analyzing and has no
interest in the human outcome on the
human impact worst possible version of
Hufflepuff is actually probably still
really cool because hufflepuffs are kind
of awesome and adorable and I love them
to death so like okay maybe they're fine
but pretty much the rest of us you take
any of any of us you push it to the
extreme worst end of these qualities
you're gonna get a horrible person and
in the case of Slytherin
yeah that's Voldemort but that's not who
we are we're not all the worst version
of ourselves
and I like to think especially over the
last few years that I have become a much
better version of myself than I've been
in the past and I hope to continue
improving and I don't think I'm doing
that in spite of or working against my
Slytherin qualities I think I'm doing
that to take best advantage of these
traits of these elements of myself that
have tripped me up before but if I can
redirect them and keep my eye on you
know the traps that I've fallen into
before I can keep changing I keep
improving I can keep evolving and I
think all of us can be the best version
of your house whatever that happens to
be again if you're Hufflepuff you'll
probably find wherever you land so
that's my ramble with no real firm
conclusion because I didn't figure out
an end point before I started so it'll
just kind of peter out there so what are
your thoughts on all of this what's your
house in Hogwarts you know what are your
feelings and general keep them
respectful I tried the IDE even if
you're like joking and you're like oh
it's just ironic if you're going like
Gryffindor socks they're inside I'm
gonna delete those comments like it
that's the nature of the discourse right
now I can't tell the difference between
you doing that as a joke and you're
doing that for real so I'm just gonna
kill it so don't do that
but short of that whatever your thoughts
are whatever your house is whatever you
want to say drop it down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
you can do cuz there's buttons and
there's links including one to my
patreon if you like what I'm doing you
want to help support me and this channel
in that way but if you don't don't worry
about it there's other links to check
out as well if you don't want to check
out any of them don't sweat it because
at the end of the day you're the council
I just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]